hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar my Chris per screens in primary
human t-cells reveal key regulators of
immune function presented by dr. Eric
Schiff root postdoctoral fellow
department of microbiology and
immunology University of California San
Francisco I'm Christie Joel of lab rats
and I'll be your moderator for today's
events today's educational web seminar
is presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo Fisher Scientific as the
world leader in serving science
Thermo Fisher Scientific mission is to
enable researchers to make the world
healthier cleaner and safer
it helps customers accelerate life
sciences research solve complex
analytical challenges and increase
laboratory productivity Thermo Fisher
Scientific offers an unmatched
combination of innovative technologies
purchasing convenience and comprehensive
services to learn more about our sponsor
please visit thermo Fisher comm
now let's get started I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation additionally if you
are viewing this webinar on demand you
may still continue to submit questions
and they will be answered via the
contact information you provided at the
kind of registration
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab sound at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and the software's
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits I now
present today's speakers dr. Eric Shifu
dr. Schiff root is a postdoctoral fellow
in Alexandra Martin's a group at the
University of California San Francisco
dr. shaprut completed his PhD at the
Weizmann Institute of Science in Israel
under the supervision of Professor near
Freedman in his thesis work dr. Schiff
root develops computational and
experimental platforms to map the
landscape of T cell receptor repertoire
in health and disease for a complete
biography on dr. shift fruit please see
the biography tab at the top of your
screen now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Schiff fruit
dr. Shephard you may now begin your
presentation
Thank You Christy for this introduction
hi everyone and thank you for joining
this webinar today I would like to share
with you what we've learned from
establishing genome-wide crisper screens
in primary unity so our motivation for
this project was the remarkable success
of immunotherapy in recent years I will
describe some of the background
information I would go through important
points to keep when performing these
poor screens and then I will describe
the results from our own screen
introduction if we think of the adaptive
immune system the problem is trying to
solve is how to pacifically recognize
and eliminate foreign pathogens while
remaining remarkably tolerant to solve
the stories is achieved by built-in
mechanisms post and prison and extrinsic
that can allow cells to recognize
foreign pathogen but avoiding healthy
tissue
unfortunately tumors can hijack these
pathways and try to recruit suppressive
cells and create an immunosuppressive
fish and by that escaping deletion by
the immune system the immunotherapy has
taught us that there are ways that we
can manipulate cells and in manipulate
their environment and how they sense
these signals to ignore suppressive
signals and create an effective response
against against tumors while very
promising there are still many
challenges that remain in current
available modalities of immunotherapy
and we are thinking of ways to engineer
cells to resist these immunosuppressive
Ishii
our overall goal is to try to find a way
to reprogram cells to ignore or
translate these suppressant signals
actually to an activated state creating
effective long lasting cures using
engineered cells the way we go about
learning the ways of how to engineer
yourself is through these unbiased
large-scale screen
so overall two types of genetic screens
are in existence pooled library screen
and as well as a raid library screen
these are very powerful tools for
magnetic discoveries and and performing
data-driven research in general arrayed
screens are perhaps more simpler to
execute in a screen like that a plate
would have a population of cells in each
well each one will have its own
perturbation gene knockout this could be
either with a certain age or crispers
base but now this plate can be
replicated and used to depth for
downstream analysis array screens as I
mentioned perhaps a more simple to
execute but they do not scale well if
you want to explore more more G knockout
you will need to perform and have more
plate for your fa when the other hand
pool screens are very easy to scale
where all cells essentially live in the
same vessel each cell will have its own
perturbation and depicted by a guide
that is integrated in that cell by
length of all particle after selection
is applied and self a pelleted genomic
DNA will allow us to perform next
generation sequencing for the guy
distribution and ask which guys are
enriched before and after selection
comparative pools crisper screens is the
ability to have this integrated barcode
overall when trying to establish a pool
screen one needs to think about the
various steps so the first steps first
step is to introduce a library of guide
this library of guides will be used to
generate a pool of plenty of oil
particles the guide the library itself
cannot be obtained either from a public
resource such as a G or if you're
interested in a targeted gene pool by
using custom synthesis and cloning the
plasmid library in half to design these
guides many of the rules have been
already figured out one example for a
very powerful tool is the CRISPR tool
which is available online
once the lens of particle pools are
generated they can be concentrated
titrated and then frozen and aliquot and
if we allow for consistency between
different replicates of the screen
one thing - to maintain and it is very
important to note in pool truth is that
the representation of the library or
coverage meaning common excel for each
guiding library exists during every step
of the screen it's maintained at a high
enough number overall that number can
range between 500 to a thousand s and
this requires a large number of cells so
when you go about doing screens in your
own cell type the one thing the
important thing to take is what is the
scale that you're comfortable culturing
yourselves in because the this coverage
is important here I'm showing from a
recent review by John Donne example
number score screen so if the size of
your library is about 100 thousand
different guides of different
perturbation and you want each of them
to be represented at least 500 times in
your library this means that you need 50
million cells that are positive
inspected in expressing the guide
transduction efficiency using the
central particles of never 100% so
assuming about 40 percent inspection
efficiency this means that you need to
start with 125 million so
on the right you can see a plot that
shows that if coverage drops below a
certain threshold the noise that is
produced at the end of the screen is so
large and basically damages the
signal-to-noise ratio and inhibit our
ability to Buckley detect our head
so adult full screen of
so far that we limited only to cell
lines that express the cat line they
believe or in transgenic mice also that
express cat line as a quick reminder the
CRISPR system requires two components
one of the cat nine enzyme and the other
with the guide that will direct the cast
line into the location in the genome a
double-stranded break will happen and
this most likely will be repaired by
error-prone mechanism resulting in a
gmail account so forecast line arm fees
we can use a synthetic cash nine protein
and a synthetic guide this will be a
sampled ex vivo and will be introduced
to cells with various methods it could
be like affection in our case we tend to
use electroporation however this does
not allow us to do a pool screen because
the cast nine and the guide will be
eventually degraded and we will have no
record of what perturbation death
Billabong undergone on the other hand as
I mentioned to try to introduce the cast
nine into the entire to using lentivirus
is quite ineffective do it due to its
very large size
so to establish pool screens in primary
human t-cell we decided to take a hybrid
approach and this experimental timeline
depicted the top we will introduce the
guide with the lentivirus and this
lentiviruses compact and we'll be able
to compute cell quite efficiently the
gas 9 which is harder to introduce by
lentivirus we were introduced by
electroporation our hope is that calf 9
will meet the in vitro transcribe the in
vivo transcribe guide will example and
will prefer will result in an effective
gene knockout we call this approach
slice for guide RNA Lenti viral
infection with cap 9 elaboration
the feasibility of this approach we use
an example guide the cd8 alpha receptor
that is highly expressed on cd8 cells
and as a control we also expressed a
guide that is called a non target and
control a sequence that does not appear
in any known region of the human genome
on the green distribution across two
donors you can see that expressing the
the CDA targeting guide effectively not
knocks out the cd8 alpha proteins in a
majority of cell whereas the cells
expressing the non targeting control at
the greatest mission maintain wild-type
level success with mr. generalizable we
also accepted a different target cd45 as
I mentioned across donors but in this
case also across different cell types
cd8 t-cells in 2014 and in both cases we
can see that the majority of cell
expressing the cd45 targeting guide lose
expression of the protein whereas the
non targeting control as I mentioned
retain their high levels of expression
this proof-of-concept showed us that we
could perform slice or basically using a
one guide library create edited 50 cells
with the traceable perturbation that can
be later read out with the next
generation sequencing pipeline so now
going from one guide through a series of
optimizations we scaled up our library
to genome-wide CRISPR knockout library
this library was obtained from algae and
in terms of Brunello library in our case
our biological question was trying to
find regulators of
human t-cell proliferation in response
to deserve stimuli so following the
slice protocol and day 14 of the culture
of cells we reintroduce them to teach
your skin before this stimulation we
also stain them with PSP or cell
proliferation dye that will allow us to
track the division of cells and perform
a sort that will enrich for dividing
cells and not dividing so later on is a
next-generation sequencing we will count
the abundance of guides in each of these
sort them and I will obtain for each
guide in the library a lot to full
change
showing us whether these guys were
enriched in dividing cells we will have
positive values or depleted in dividing
cells we will have negative log for
change values
so in this representation I'm showing
the distribution of a lot code changing
in the entire library for three example
positive hits and three examples
negative head and this representation
each line is a guide targeting the gene
that is depicted on the left and for
these hallmark negative regulators of
TCR signaling bb/d 5-3 a you can see
that multiple guides targeting the same
gene are showing enrichment in the
dividing cell whereas on the other hand
essential components of these are
signaling that one - between Delta and
LTP to are all showing a depletion from
the dividing cells and enrichment in the
non-dividing so this is another
advantage of the full screen because we
have redundancy not only of self per
guide but also of guide per gene and
different creases that our confidence in
the head were multiple guide targeting
the same gene are showing the same trend
can now look at all heads in our library
and in the volcano plot on the y-axis
you can see how significant the hit is
on the gene level and on the access you
can see if it's either a positive or a
negative thing so on the left side we
can see that many essential components
of TCR signaling P of them we already
mentioned LTP - 2 D 3 Delta and f1 are
shown to be enriched in the non-dividing
cells the more may be serve particularly
interesting part is the right hand of
this plot showing symbol be invested EA
many others that were described in
literature but also a large number of
novel regulators
to show that our screen is reproducible
and these hits are not a result of some
cancel off target effect we we perform
the same screen again with two new
donors at a genome-wide level and asked
whether these hits are now appearing in
both screen so in this representation
I'm showing the the normalized log
fortunes for the first screen on the
x-axis and for the second screen on the
wire so things that fall on the diagonal
are actually reproducible between two
screen and many bearer hits as I
mentioned seem to be heads in both
streams increasing our confidence that
these are a true hit
to try to annotate the collection of
Jean Jean we took the gene set
enrichment analysis approach trying to
find pathways better enriched in both
sides of the screen on the bottom right
we can see that many of the essential
TCR signaling components as depicted by
the kegg pathway database are indeed
depleted or receiving a negative log for
change course in our screen on the right
red box we can see the top candidates
for that again up will be to that one
but also to decree Delta K and others on
the other side of the screen a gene that
when they're knocked out actually
increase the ability of cells to respond
to teach our signaling by increased
proliferation
there were there was no literature or
there was no bioinformatics database
that collected all of them under the
same list but through literature search
we found shRNA in vivo screen that it
was down was done in life in a tumor
model were put in one piece of or
introduced with library as a journey and
then they're allowed to infer David
tumors the authors asked which guide
allowed cell to survive in the tumor
tissue to our surprise meant and we're
very content many of our negative
regulators that were found in the
genome-wide CRISPR screen in human T
cells were also hit and the in vivo
mouse cream so it will be soft warm uka
and dead June were all found both in our
screen but also they leave a a screen
done in my targeted towards finding
immunotherapy
you
now that we have a
list of candidates and hit from our
screen we aim to validate them and the
that they reproduce their function also
in a condiment system collapse
we took the second approach for genetic
screens which is arranged and an
experiment experimental common like that
we take CGA T cells from different
donors we introduced gene knockouts by
using synthetic caste 9 assembled with
synthetic guide RNA in a plate
these are assembled and introduce the T
cells by electroporation now we create a
raise of states of edited T cells each
well having a homogeneous population of
cells with a single gene knocked out for
each gene in our list of candidates
we use two different guy now this space
can be that we can be used for
downstream center piping analysis both
to validate their ability to increase
proliferation based on secrecy but also
to look at a activation event and see if
they're affected by the Gmail count
um here I'm trying our top two
candidates that will be in 55 and to
talk to rode across two donors and to
guide directed at okay not busy and the
fifty see this commission and agree
shows us that civil be and thirty-five
increased proliferation in response to
this to be our stimulus as the
non-targeted control in the third row
from the top shows a very little
recreation on the other hand of CP 2
which is the essential gene for TCR
signaling when this member is not out so
are completely unable to respond to
their stimulus and they remain
non-dividing same as van simulator cells
degrade across all panels
the ability of heads to increased
proliferation we fitted the speaker to
distribution in gas in curve this allows
us to extract the quantitative parameter
called the proliferation index which is
a indicator for how strong self
politically when we normalize this
equation index to the non certain
control we can see that many heads from
our pool screen as well validate their
ability to increase proliferation in
their rate screen
we do note that some of them and do not
validate and these are interested
interesting by themselves and we're
following up on them
as I mentioned the right screens that
I'll for multiplex on typing and not
only that you can look at see if I see a
few days later we can also look at what
are the possible mechanisms that are
driving the increased proliferation so
one hypothesis is these these events are
driven by increased activation state we
use to example our protein noted further
up regulation during early event a
downstream of Casey are similar to the
69 sed 154 or 340 Lycan
and looked at their ability to increase
excavation state six hours both exposure
to these are stimulants again we are
normalizing to the non turbine control
the second from the bottom and overall
many of our heads from the screen are
actually inducing heightened or elevated
activation state for the same time point
compared to the monitor control again
our essential component SCP to when it's
knocked out disabled the self from even
going to the activated state
you
another form of what we can do with
these now plates or arrays of edited
details is basically to look at their
ability to interact with other cells in
our case the relevant context was their
ability to cook to kill tumor cells to
do that and to introduce an antigen
specific kill we also needed to
introduce the transgenic PCR in this
case we need the model system of the
onesie for TCR that recognizes then ways
of peptide in a native context so we
will in this experimental timeline we
will introduce the TCR with the length
bars
we will then edit the cells with cast
nineties we will talk over them with 8 -
7 5 in a normal cell line that also
expected an rfp in its nucleus
yes our fear will allow us to count
cells using live cell imaging and look
at other the proliferation of the
melanoma cells or they're killing by the
T cell
to see that the system work we first
show that we're able to over express the
ny0
specifically PR and primary immunity so
across to donors and it's very high
efficiency
um
control we also looked at if the PCR or
the t-cells are killing a 2005 an
enormous Airlines in this co culture
model in a specific way so we should see
that there's also a dependency on the
ratio between theta 2 and 5 cell line
and cd8 to the toxic T cells as we
introduced clear impurity so the HSN
five are allowed to grow and this is
depicted on the bottom two panel the
upper panels shows us that this killing
of a 275 by T cells is dependent on
cafes activity showing that this is a
true tattoo topic right cytotoxic a
functional resume looking at the cells
the respondent cells the cancer cell
line 36 hours after call culture if we
don't introduce any T cells different
invasion survive on a panel cells grow
uncontrollably when we introduce new
cells that are specific to a 2005 but
are knocked out for non targeting
control there is some clearance of the
tumor cells however remarkably when we
introduce four of our candidate tips or
attitudes it will be platforming
sequences you can see that the clearance
is much higher indicating that these
engineered T cells now have a boosted
ability to clear the tumor cells
you
to quantify this over time we can look
at the account of a certain size so
throughout the culture because this
plate is now under continuous live cell
imaging monitoring so whereas the
non-trading control cells as I mentioned
are able to clear some of the tumour
cells these four candidates to see
because ox monitor will be and let the
two were able to clear the tumor cells
much fat as again as the counter example
SCP - it's knock out a disable the
t-cell from recognizing within the a to
certain file and allow the HSN card - to
grow uncontrollable uncontrollably
so we were very happy with the pipeline
or discovery platform that we've
established here we've done unbiased
genome-wide cream in a pooled fashion in
community cells we took the candidate
head validated variability in using
array screens but also looked at their
functional capacity to kill tumor cells
using the Skype cell imaging pop culture
assay
as additional
development we can supplement the
discovery power of pool trees by not
only using teacher stimulus but also
using a suppressive force if you
remember our original motivation is to
try to find ways to engineer t-cells to
exist they mean a suppressive niche that
is created by tumors one way to mimic
this that we went about is using antenna
beam agonist identity is very very high
levels in tumor microenvironment and act
as suppressor of detailed preparation so
in our case we wanted to ask the
question can we find through the genetic
screen perturbations that would make
cells resistant to identity so in the
same way that I've described before
we've performed this genome-wide screen
but now we also add in an arm where we
add a mimic of the identity to a
signaling and this is a synthetic
inhibitor and can be added easily to the
media using the same approach we looked
at the weather the
the hibbett er suggests 21-0 does indeed
inhibit yourself from proliferating and
you can see based on the CPC
distribution there's definitely fear
dividing cells compared to the vehicle
control on now same way as before we can
take these two short bands of dividing
and non-dividing itself and as can we
find guides or gene knockout that allow
cells to resist the presence of the
agonist
and this bottom I'm showing you the the
log fold change normalized on the x-axis
where diagonal is not going to do this
is just a vehicle control and on the
y-axis we're showing the love fold
change when the adenosine agonist is
added they mentioned that the zagnut is
specific to the adenosine a to a
receptor and we were very happy to see
that right on the y axis you can see
that the gene a door to aid and codes
were they to a magazine receptor it's
specifically enriched and only when we
add the dead that is in agony so this is
the nice one to control but also we
could find a previously uncharacterized
protein 5 1 5 a and this is the first
time and it's been associated with
response to identity learning we did the
same coach and validated both these hit
the a to a adore receptor and also fam 1
5 a showing here across two donors that
they're actually specific only to the
presence of the identity negative we
took this even further to a co culture
system and control did it while the non
terminal control cells are inhibited
from from killing or clearing the bases
in 5 min and all myself
the knockouts for tour to a and also our
noble hit 5 10 1 5 a are able to resist
the effect of the higher division
agonist and maintain wild-type skill and
level
so this is one way of enriching the the
type of information that you can take
from these pool screen and the last
platform that I'll share with you today
also allows for enriching the type of
data that you can get from the pools so
in recent years both Petrucci can crop
seek have emerged as ways of coupling a
pooled critical screen together with
single cell and they should output it at
the other end this now allows for gives
very high rich dataset that allows you
to compare a pool of guides and their
downstream effects at the transcript
level to achieve this one needs to
capture the the guide sequence using any
single cell identica platform however
the the guide RNA is because it's
contrived by a poetry promoter does not
have a poly a tail the caustic platform
that was published about two years ago
solve this in a very clever way where
it's integrating the guide cassette
within the LCR region that eventually
would be duplicated once it's integrated
into genome this creates two cassettes
of the guide RNA one that will be used
for the genome editing but the other one
will be transcribed by the exponent
alpha promoters having eventually a poly
a tail this will allow it to be captured
by any polyb T and downstream platform
in our case we use the ten economic
platform as I mentioned let's now create
a very rich data fit for every single
cell not only will you get a
transcriptome but also which guide was
expressed there and you can start as
question of
what is the relationship between a
perturbation and downstream of that so
we perform our sliced platform but now
instead of sorting cells at the end we
actually submitted them using the
because we use the proper crops
acceptors in a targeted library with 48
candidates guides we can use downstream
single cell and you seek and try to now
explore in what ways our perturbations
are increasing cells like so ability to
activate and proliferate in response
system I should mention that has a
control arm for this expanse we also
took cells that we introduced the
library to but did not expose the TCR
stimulus
following we signals are in sequencing
you tend to get these like high
dimensional maps that describe the gene
expression across all cells in your
library so in this depiction here you
can see that there are regions in the
side dimensional maps are more
associated with twice themselves or
resting so this is depicted by high
expression of the io7 receptor for
instance and this e07
chemical I'm sorry on the other hand on
the right hand side of each of these the
high dimensional map we can see the
highly pure protein cells indicated by
ki-67 which is a cell cycle G's but also
their cytotoxic abilities is increased
detected by grand plan B
now that we have the gene expression map
you can start asking are they related to
the perturbation the cells of undergone
the reminder cell now not only that you
know the gene expression but also which
guide was expressed there so far our two
top candidates will be incident five you
can see that they're clustered all felt
that have stable being 35 are clustered
in the right hand side of the hyda
mention map exactly where put it where
these cells fall where else 52 the
negative head push itself towards the
left hand side of the block where the
resting cell are the nonprofit in
control are evenly distributed across
this high dimension we can now create a
map of cell states by sub clustering
cells based on their gene expression and
ask whether guides fall together within
the same cluster and overall we can now
start digging deeper into the type of
data and and try to learn which guide
for which perturbations tend to push
cells to have a more common adult baked
not so for instance in this example
quarter one and torso case with resting
self and so we can see depletion of
symbol B and C D 5 and B K and B and so
on from these clusters and we can see
enrichment of the LCP to CD 2 Delta
guide clusters 10 11 and 12 they're so
simple if reading self have various
combinations of the perturbation
enriched in them
so to summarize what I've shown you here
today we've established a very powerful
discovery platform that allows us to do
unbiased genetic screen using the CRISPR
cast 9 system and as an example we
showed this in primary human t-cells and
more specifically in cd8 t-cells asking
the question of can we describe the
regulators teachers perforation and
responsive to their stimulus you use
this essay to to screen as I mentioned
and find guides that will increase the
cell ability to to function interest
rate
the hit that we've got from this screen
and also showed that there knock out can
increase the cell's ability to kill
cancer cells in the in vitro culture
and with that that is an agonist example
I've shown you that a suppressive force
can be added to the pool screen to try
to explore in our mechanisms that make
self resistant to inhibitory signal
so I will end just by showing you an
overview of the slice platform as I
mentioned now this enables these
large-scale unbiased genetic screens in
primary t-cells for the first time you
can use any commercially available
off-the-shelf guide RNA library
and cat signs introduced by by
electroporation this now allows you to
explore many different biological
functions of the cells we chose to focus
on T cell proliferation using the race
screen part of this platform you can now
start asking ourselves actually
proliferating and activating more
strongly when these genes are knocked
out and can also performing co-culture
assay finally I showed you that using
single serenade sequencing you can now
create these like high dimensional maps
and create relationship between guy
perturbation and downstream cell trait I
will just end by acknowledging the
people involved in this project first
joey Carnevale who is a clinical fellow
in the Asheville plant here in UCSF and
my mentor Alex Marcin and members of the
Marcin lab that help with performing new
screen or pankkar funding resources on a
thank everyone for their attention and
I'm happy to take any questions thank
you
thank you dr. Shepherd for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box and click send
one serves many of your questions as we
have time for ok our first question
dr. chef Ruth
can the slice protocol you described to
be adopted to perform genome-wide screen
with other types of cells such as
neurons cells and what are the potential
challenges
that's an excellent question so in
essence the two requirements for
performing genome-wide screens in this
slide platform is one that you should be
able to transduce yourself with Lenti
viral particle and the other you should
be able to grow them in large numbers
actually the number of cells that you're
able to culture comfortably determines
the size of the lobby so in a case where
I don't have experiences with germ cells
specifically but in a case where the
cell number is the limiting factor this
using the the coverage that we
calculated back to what type of work
what is the size of the library that you
can accommodate in your screen so once
an alliteration protocol is found for
the your target cell and you know that
you can transduce it yourself
essentially you can perform a slice to
any type of common cell we've shown it
to work also in other type of T cells as
I showed in the beginning but we're now
also it's for another immune cell types
I would say that when people antivirus
is start to be able to transduce also
quite as himself so it could be that no
one cells can express a guide out of the
mental bulk yes
and dr. Shepherd how many sgrna s are
used per gene for genome-wide screen
so I would say that generally the the
number you can you try to keep around
five hundred to a thousand cells per
guide in your library and the libraries
that we've used as mentioned Brunello
library that is designed by John Donne
and is available on a G they chose to
use for guide Virginia library this
number ranges between obscene libraries
with with four guides the most compact
up to ten guides per June as I mentioned
the decide to the library also
determines in of ourselves you'll need
to culture so I would be
careful not to increase the size of the
library just to do to have redundancy of
guides in our experience the four guides
for gene if you maintain sufficient
coverage is enough for many biological
systems
now could you please share how to
minimize off-target impact based on your
experience
you
um yeah so when the the crisper cat 9
systems were starting to be more and
more popular it was obvious that some of
the ailments of the earlier perturbation
platforms such as etcetera name
we're less of a concern and the CRISPR
system it's fairly robust and off
targets are quite minimal the the nice
thing about a postman as I mentioned
because of the redundancy that occurs in
several different levels both many cells
expressed the same guide and their
multiple guides targeting a gene and in
our case we also performed the screening
and multiple donors in multiple times
the effects of of off target cutting is
reduced to basically negligible levels
so I wouldn't worry too much about our
target effect in these commercially
available screen library soy and our
know that for every screen there will be
a validation page that follows and that
this allows you to use different guide
for the same gene not necessarily the
guide that were present in the library
really reducing the target attack
Thank You dr. Schiff fruit and it looks
like we're almost out of time so this
will have to be our last question what
software algorithm was used for sliced
with single-cell RNA safe data analysis
and could you please specify how to
perform data analysis
yeah I'm happy to a the rival complex
system I agree so first you need to be
comfortable with analyzing tables there
are any sequence data sets to begin with
the tools available for that are now in
very active development and people gain
more and more experience the field
getting better at creating a platform we
used a combination of a publicly
available powerful package to analyzing
autonomic sequencing called suet and and
I recommend this package for every type
of single scientific data set the
complexity that is added with popsicle /
tip stick is that now for every cell you
also have an identity tag the tells in
which guide would express there in our
course we took a very straightforward
algorithm we just used a chi-square test
to ask whether you can find an enriched
Association of guide in certain closes I
think has these again per to speak or a
pools we coupled with phenolphthalein
sequencing data sets become more and
more popular there will be dedicated
tools and algorithms that we be tailored
to the type of the
thank you dr. Shugart did you have any
final comments for our audience
um yeah thank you all for listening and
for these are in fact is a question I'm
available by email if anyone wants to
contact me with follow-up questions and
and I wish you good luck
again that dr. Shephard for your time
today and your important research I
would also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsors Thermo Fisher Scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast before we go a final thank you
to our audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on-demand and laberd's
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
thanks for joining us and we hope to see
you next time goodbye